so I actually watched the entire season
so I'm like nine weeks advance of like
everyone else wow crazy let's go uh and
some reviewers they only got the first
four episodes but I have all nine
episodes
I see that all the way to the end
um
for people who don't know uh well you
know it's the last of us to hit
PlayStation 3 video game from 2013.
um and this show is pretty much like
really really similar to the game like
like like like like I I like I almost
said but like I'll say it right now I
think this is the most faithful video
game adaptation like like ever made like
because they wow like it's the same it's
the same lines from the game that's in
the show
maybe they might tweak a few words or
like an article here or there or like
maybe the circumstances of the lines
might be a little bit different but like
they are saying the same lights like
every single scene that you think is
your favorite The Last of Us they do it
they do it exactly the same way in the
show